really the difference between rich  people and poor people poor people play  the lottery they're trying to only focus  on the upside and they're almost happy  to give away a guaranteed downside  meaning they're willing to pay money  that they know they're going to lose to  potentially make more rich people never  lose money and would take a very small  upside knowing that they're guaranteed  to not lose the money to put in which is  why rich people are putting a hundred  percent of their net worth in crypto  because all of that is upside but  there's still a potential for downside  so they'll put a small percentage into  that versus all the poorest people i  know have 100 of the net worth in crypto  and it could vanish tomorrow and that's  the difference between buying lottery  tickets and investing